Rom Eliaz, thank you so much
for taking the time to be on the show.
Sure, my pleasure.
Thank you, Michael,
for hosting me.
Really, I just want to mention, Rom,
before we start that we had a session
a few hours ago
that we were about to start.
And you are coming out
of the hospital with a mask.
And you were telling me
that you're working
on some different studies
in regards to covid.
And I just got so much inspiration
from that, and I was so happy
that we're delaying talk,
because you're doing such important work
in biomedical.
So, first of all, thank you
for all the amazing work
that you're doing.
And now, please, yes,
tell me a little bit about yourself.
Sure, I will be more than happy to.
So, basically,
I was born and raised in Israel.
And basically,
one of the four big cities in Israel.
But is actually,
the what's called Be'er Sheva,
which is basically,
the "queen" of the desert.
Or the "capital" of the desert in Israel.
There are four main cities.
And Be'er Sheva is the
less appreciating one.
The north there is  Haifa, Tel Aviv,
Jerusalem and Be'er Sheva.
[--],
Haifa in the north.
There's Tel Aviv, Jerusalem,
and  then, Be'er Sheva in the south.
But it's David Ben-Gurion's
favorite city.
So, that's what counts.
That's true.
[--]
And, he went to [--].
Long story short, I learned
chemical engineering and biotechnology
in Ben-Gurion University,
and Weizmann Institute.
I did my bachelor degree,
and then my PhD in both university.
While I was in my PhD, I came across
a few patents that we developed.
And then, I told that we would like to
maybe start a new startup company
around our patents.
So, I decided that I want to be
an executive and maybe the CEO
of the company.
So, I decided that I need to learn MBA.
So, I went to an MBA program.
That was the most important
because an MBA get started with
the professors from a Harvard University
and Boston University in Israel.
During my last year of my PhD,
which was my second year of my MBA,
my professor in Ben-Gurion decided to go
and start a company in MIT
with Bob Langer, it's a huge name
in the field of drug delivery
and making other devices.
So, I wrote a letter
to the dean of Harvard and saying,
Give you the true Boston program,
I would like to do
my second year in Boston
while I'm actually writing my PhD in MIT.
And that's what happened.
I moved to Harvard for a year.
I wrote my PhD during the day in MIT.
And I went to school, I mean,
Harvard Business School.
And that's where my first experience
with the US.
And then, graduated.
And went to do my postdoc,
in UCSF, in University of California,
San Francisco.
Once I was there, I learned,
I actually enjoyed myself
in a basketball game.
And long story short,
I was in bed on my second week
of my postdoc,
in bed for six weeks,
basically cannot move anywhere.
What did you do?
You're playing basketball.
How do you go to bed for six weeks?
Oh, because I got my ACL torn apart,
my meniscus tear.
I went to play basketball,
and then, I was injured,
and then, I needed to have surgery.
And while I was waiting for the surgery,
I'm getting full recovery,
I basically wrote a grant for the NIH.
I got a five million dollar grant.
We wrote a few pointers in cancer research
about the grant.
I then make a grant from the cancer,
tobacco research in the UCSF.
And from [--],
I award a scholarship.
So, it was another one.
And then, actually I won
five million dollars grant,
which was a lot of money then.
It's a lot of money now too.
Yeah. I wrote a few papers
in cancer research, and a year later,
I got an assistant professor in UCSF.
So, I was an assistant professor
in UCSF and UC Berkeley
for the gene therapy, drug delivery,
and biomedical engineering.
And then, living in the Silicon Valley,
you basically see all these entrepreneurs.
And I take my MBA, and I knew
that what I really want to do
is to start my own company
and really help humanity
with some new invention
and new things that we did.
So, I was lucky enough
to actually have a few patents
in my PhD thesis.
But also, in my postdoc.
So, I was working on tissue engineering.
And then, work with some medical devices
and try [--].
So, we wrote a few more patents.
We wrote a few for more papers.
We're trying to start a new company.
But, I then was asked,
after actually giving a lecture in London,
to join a company called ALZA.
ALZA was a company in Silicon Valley
started by Alejandro Zaffaroni.
And that time, it was 3000 people.
I joined.
They actually asked me to join
around 1999.
That was the Y2K.
Long story short,
I joined them a year later.
Actually a year and a half later in 2001.
And then, the company was acquired
half a year later
by  Johnson & Johnson.
So, in my first exit,
I basically was lucky.
I was in the right place
at the right time.
And once ALZA was acquired
for $12.3 billion,
all the management went to start
Jazz Pharmaceutical.
So, I was lucky enough to be on the side
to basically go to the management
of the whole portfolio of drug delivering
of Johnson & Johnson and ALZA.
Yeah. I was in Johnson & Johnson
for about three years.
One thing I want to say before I continue,
if someone tell you
that luck is not important,
it is important.
And a better luck is always better
than any other thing
that you are doing.
Rom, I think, you can definitely say
that luck is important, but at the end,
up until this point where you're seeing
that luck is important,
you've already managed to do your PhD
on biotech.
You've already done your MBA
through Harvard.
So, let's just say that, yes,
luck may be important,
but in your case,
I think your record speaks for yourself
in terms of your profession and ability.
I think that if you are working hard
and you're trying to go
to the right places,
the luck will go with you.
So, at the end of the day,
if you are really doing what you need,
and even if you fail,
eventually, things will go with you.
Anyway, I was at ALZA.
I was there for about four years.
After four years, they wanted me to move
to New Brunswick in the East Coast.
I didn't want to move.
So, I actually join a small company.
I was employee number five
in a small company called [--].
A company that was started in Palo Alto.
I was doing,
was basically was a spinoff
from Genentech,
when Genentech wanted to go
only to Oncology to spill out
all the neurodegenerative diseases.
Arnon Rosenthal was the head
of neurodegenerative diseases
at Genentech, started this company
called Rinat Neuroscience.
Today, all you guys living in West Coast
know there is a building of Pfizer
called Rinat, in South San Francisco.
That was where the original Rinat was.
Rinat was acquired by Pfizer
two and a half years later
for like $500 million.
And we have one antibody for Alzheimer.
We have one antibody for pain.
And we have one antibody for migraine,
which called the anti CGRP.
All of these,
except of the Alzheimer,
are basically drugs.
One is a drug by Pfizer for pain.
The other one
is a drug by Teva for migraine.
Rom, I have to stop you here.
Because I have to understand,
what is the commonality between
all these things that you've worked on?
I mean, it sounds like all of them
are very very meaningful.
They improve the lives of many.
They're very challenging professionally
because you're actually inventing
new drugs.
You're inventing new treatments
for a lot of these.
I mean, just as when
you were an assistant professor,
you co-authored over 40 publications.
Where does this curiosity come from
and this motivation to build businesses,
or to help run businesses,
while at the same time
helping millions of people
around the world with your inventions?
I think it's coming from youth.
So, you know what you're going to do.
I was, I have a cleft palate.
I was a child that was dealing
with doctors all my life
because I was treated by them.
I was fascinated by this medical field.
I wanted to be a doctor.
In Israel,  you have to go to the army.
I couldn't go through the army to,
I wanted to be a doctor.
The army wanted me to go
and learn physics and computers.
I said, "I don't want to."
They actually gave me
my own program at the time.
It was a patent called Talpiot
I didn't want to go there.
They gave me a special one.
But at the end of the day, I think,
it's really coming from where,
I felt that all my life, I really wanted
to help society and to help people.
I really wanted to be a doctor
all my life, or, a violin player.
Then, when I was like 17 years old,
I actually attempted to Juilliard.
But I decided that I'm not going to.
Okay. Rom, rega. One is rega. Hold on.
I have to breathe. one second.
First of all, my brother wanted,
Yeah. That's exactly
what I'm feeling right now.
My brother went to Juilliard.
And so, it's very close to heart.
I just want to recap.
The Army wants you to go to Talpiot,
you're probably the first person
in the history of the nation of Israel,
that declines that offer
so that they give you your own program.
You get accepted to Juilliard, which,
and everybody knows this is like
the most prestigious school
in the world, for music.
I saw my brother, with blood,
sweat and tears, all his life
until he got accepted there
and had a phenomenal experience
in the university.
You don't go to Juilliard, right?
Because you're not a violinist now.
You're a venture capital in Biomed.
So, you forgo Juilliard.
I'm still playing the violin.
And I still have my own 2Cds.
And I'm still playing today.
I'm playing with friends.
So, that's the beauty about music.
And violin,  in general,
you always can do it as a hobby.
You don't have to do it as a profession.
So, you don't go to Juilliard,
but you continue.
And, I can't believe, I'm already sad
that we only have a few minutes left.
But Rom, I have to get
your perspective today.
You're in venture capital.
You're investing as a part
of so many different funds,
one of them J-Ventures,
which we're both a part of.
But, I mean, what is it about
this biomedical field
that really intrigues you?
And where are we headed now?
So, I mean, as a young entrepreneur,
I want to learn, what are
the most exciting things in the field,
and where can I put my time and effort
into helping others?
I think, that one of the most
important thing in general,
not only in a medicine and medical,
but anything in life, is that,
if you attack a problem
you need to attack it
from different angles.
And that's exactly where medical field
is going now.
If you think about collaboration now,
between the high tech and the biotech,
you can see that basically now,
with all the AI, and machine learning,
and all the digital health,
you can basically get so many data.
I'm able to collect in the past
in a big data, and basically analyze it
not only from the perspective
of only biology,
or how long you're looking
into antibodies or drugs,
but then, you also can see
how they affect.
Basically, it's a combination
of bioinformatic,
that was known in the past.
Now, with the big data,
and took it to gain the collaboration
between all these fields.
Like the neural cells, and the big data,
the AI, the machine learning.
All the data and knowledge that we have,
from the medical field,
this is where the world is going.
It's still going to be,
at the end of the day, you still will need
to go back to the old biology
and find the new targets,
and the new therapies for every drug.
But the way there,
might be much much shorter.
You can be much more accurate.
And basically, the world is going towards
personalized medicine.
So, there's not going to be
any more capsules, or pills,
or anything that you are taking is going,
and not even antibody,  that are good for,
let's say, about 25% or 2% of the society.
Each person is going to have
a gene editing or gene analysis.
And by knowing that,
and knowing exactly what are
the expression of genes
and receptors that you have,
you would know exactly how to target.
And eventually, I'm thinking
that it's going to be a collaboration
of MEMS of nano particles.
You know, the great Isaac Asimov,
which he wrote on the voyage,
the wonderful voyage.
I forgot the name of the book.
Basically, when you have
a little submarine,
that's going into the vein,
and can actually go through your body
and really see what are the problem
and solve it, that's something
where the field is going.
Everything's going to be targeted.
It's going to be collaboration with me,
between engineering, biology,
and basically hi-tech.
Rom, I think this is just inspiring.
What made you do the transition
from an entrepreneur
and tech executive to venture capital?
And how much time are you spending
on either aspects
of your professional career now?
Are you mostly focusing on one of them?
Or, is it always a balance
in between the two?
I think, it's always a balance.
And, it's so important to understand,
when you are investing
in this biotech field,
you really need to understand
what is the field.
You need to understand,
how time things are taking.
At the end of the day, it's always people,
and it's always technologies.
And again, people people people.
But, you need to understand
this technology here,
because you need to know
how to make the right investment.
And then, at the end of the day,
you're investing in peoples.
And you need people that know
how to solve a situation.
That can solve a difficult situation.
How to solve a crisis.
Because everything in startup,
you can see a great business plan.
But, at the end of the day,
nothing is close to the business plan.
It's going completely to a different way.
That's why, the people,
is the most important thing in everything.
And, at the end of the day,
if you have good people,
and you have the right collection of people
from different fields,
you always will be able to do
all these stuff.
But, I'm also assuming that
that in the companies that you invest
in the medical space,
they're not the average,
Silicon Valley company.
That's another social media app,
or another consumer product.
This is more long term research
that the research is the business, right?
The IP of the company and the knowledge,
I mean, if it either works
and then it's hugely successful,
or, it doesn't work and then it dies down.
Is that the right comparison?
I mean, we are always looking
for the cutting edge technology.
Always for the next thing,
for something that is unknown.
For something that is the next thing,
because this is the field.
If you want to invest and you can do that.
You can be a generic,
you can be made to,
you can be a lot of things.
But if you want to be an entrepreneur,
and you really want to take a risk,
you really need to invest
in a cutting edge technology
and taking a risk in life.
You need to know that sometimes
you're taking your own cab,
or you're taking gamble
on the wrong application.
But then, at the end of the day,
if you are looking on a variety
and a nice portfolio of situations,
at the end of the day,
you probably, hopefully, will be able
to target it all.
To be the winner of at least one or two.
You need only one Google.
And you need only one Facebook.
You need only one [--].
At the end of the day,
if you are even to get this one,
then you will have enough funds
to actually invest in other
[--] and cutting edge.
At the end of the day, you never know.
Even a failure technology,
at the end of the day can become merge
to another technology.
And it happened.
It happened that we went
from one technology, it didn't work.
But when we merge it with others,
at the end of the day,
maybe even five years later,
or maybe even 10 years later,
because the market wasn't ready.
Or, the technology wasn't there yet.
It's still, the dreams can become true.
OK, so the question for myself,
I'm an engineer.
I'm studying artificial intelligence
at university now.
But I definitely want to see myself
being an active part into the space
that you're in right now,
because, I mean,
that's where the future is.
And this is what is actually
going to either save,
or at least magnify and help
the lives of millions of people,
if not billions of people
around the world.
If I want to be an entrepreneur
in your space, and I have the expertise
in computer science and machine learning,
do I also need to go and pursue academics
in biology or biotech?
Or, is it enough that I find
the right partners who can complement
my knowledge with their knowledge
and go that?
So, this is a serious question
that I'm wondering
what's the right path for me?
No. You don't need to be all of them.
For my perspective,
I always like to know a lot of things.
So, you don't need to have
a degree in biology, or something.
You definitely need to work
with the right people.
But, if you ask me,
I will definitely recommend
that you would take some advanced classes,
or, you will take some classes
or something in the field.
You will always try
to learn more and more.
It's a never ending process like Fortgame.
I have a degree
black belt in martial arts.
And basically, what I'm saying,
never ending excellence.
You never can stay in your comfort zone.
Always you need to get
to improve yourself,
to get better, to know better.
I wasn't trying to overachieving this,
and really trying to go
out of your comfort zone.
And all the time,
learn and learn and learn.
Eventually, you will get to drag
people around you.
You will find the right people.
But again,  you need to know
one thing really really well.
And if you are really good
in your AI and machine learning,
excel in it. Be an expert in it.
So, be a point of excellence
from AI in your team.
But, definitely try to surround yourself
with a team of people
coming from the biotech,
Especially if you want to go into biotech,
people that know how to do business.
And then, once you decide
to do something in the field,
definitely try and learn about it.
You don't need to be expert.
You don't need to be the best person
in the room, in the field.
But definitely try to understand
what they are talking about.
So, you know what's going on
around you.
Rom, I am so inspired by this talk.
Thank you again for giving me your time.
Right before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Definitely, Motivation.
Never ending improvement.
What is this big one?
And, Never stop to dream.
Always dream.
And once dream a dream,
try to achieve it and make it coming true.
Wow. Rom, thank you for saving lives.
Thank you for making the world better.
That's all I have to say.
And I'm definitely going to keep you
in the loop.
And I'm thankful for this friendship
and relationship.
And I'm going to come back
for more and more advice over the years.
So, thank you.
Will be more than happy to.
Thank you, Michael.
Thank you. Take care. Bye bye.
Bye bye.